i mean i would say every career path has
their own obstacles
especially especially like for example
if i would take engineering for example
it's actually
not advantageous to you to do like to do
a good job in your company and stay in
that company because like the raises you
get are better if you move companies and
you're constantly moving companies right
and that you know i don't think that
should be right because i think you
should be i think every employee should
be rewarded for doing a good job at that
company yeah but the sad reality of it
of it is is that a lot of the times in a
lot of career paths you can get a much
better raise by changing companies and
then moving back to the original company
and you're thinking like why can't i
just why can't the original company just
see me for my worth to begin with it's
like twitch streamers moving to youtube
[Music]
free privileged
individuals justify that you know the
one thing that
the one comment that i absolutely i i
know i'm just i'm inviting this comment
okay you've changed
i like the old blank better and it's
like
are you saying that i should i would be
the same person i am at 20 years old
that i am now because you're insane
however if you think that i should be
the same person of course i'm going to
change yeah if i didn't do youtube i
would still change it would change
regardless i'm becoming more miserable
jain
you change right and when people comment
saying like oh they've changed you know
they're different from like yes of
course as you should you should become
more confident as you get i would be
worried i would be worried if you didn't
change right you should you should
mature you should change your opinion
you should act differently that's that's
called life if you're not doing that
what are you doing yeah what are you why
why aren't you changing why aren't you
improving yourself yeah exactly you know
but then i guess that's but then yeah
that's the thing it's like
instead of going to primark how dare you
it all changed when conor got this
pumpkin spice latte at starbucks for the
first time you have changed it all
changed
[Laughter]
that one trip to los angeles has changed
seriously
i'm not gonna be broke anymore
no but i mean i agree you should or you
should always be changing you know i i
think there is a difference between
changing and uh you know becoming a bit
snobby
yeah because you know for like i still
can't stand
what i said i still can't stand
um
flex culture
yeah well it's weird isn't it because
you want to be able to celebrate and
support the people who have really
worked hard and have done great stuff
and have made some good content and you
you know you i i want to see them like
do well yeah but then i guess there's a
very fine line especially for audiences
yeah what is considered flexing and what
is yeah i'm not i'm not going to go
around be like oh this is what i bought
i'm doing i'm killing it you know all my
investments are doing well right
i got into stocks when everyone got on
the stocks and i've been in the red for
a very long time
so there's no flexing from me
unfortunately
um
but it is a fine line between like what
is flexing and what is just being proud
of your accomplishments right yeah
it's it's like what what is that how
when does it change [ __ ] it's hard isn't
it because you don't want to be like
yeah i'm doing well but you also you
know because
some people perceive that as
you've changed
yeah right so what do you do not want me
to like show you my achievements or
because people people support small
creators and then they also
turn on them when they're when they find
out they're doing well sometimes which
is yeah
it's the underground band going
yesterday it is yeah just just just in a
different field you know they've changed
everything ever since they were
successful and signed by the music label
you know don't like their music anymore
they're talking about different things
i like them before they became an
animator
you know i i i don't get annoyed if
someone prefers all the content of mine
or they prefer because the style has
changed yeah right and i understand that
when you change your style not every
style is for everyone exactly and i
don't get annoyed and people like i
prefer the old videos i'm like that's
fair enough right like i get it like
it's your taste all right yeah but i'm
not going to change it because that's
not what i want to do yeah i mean i i
still get comments who are uh that are
still like i miss the anime zone when
are you gonna bring back the anime zone
reviews and i'm just like dude i killed
off reviews for like a [ __ ] reason
okay yes i have changed in that sense
i'm not doing anime yeah i'm not doing
anime zone reviews anymore i mean people
still ask me for my [ __ ] let's plays
i'm like
but then i also get annoyed at content
creators that like whine at their
audience all the goddamn time right
they're like oh why are you complaining
you don't like the new videos it's like
it's it's you need you need to go out
your way and make something yeah it's
different you can't expect your audience
to just follow suit and and like yeah
it's it's up to you yeah sometimes you
just have to be like just screw what the
audience thinks if this is what makes
you happy
i hate i hate youtubers that sit there
and make videos whining that they're not
doing well yeah i'm like get over it
it's you you if you do something else if
you change something or you're doing
you're not making like stuff that is
keeping up with the times yeah that's on
you i believe yeah that that is part of
the job that you signed up for exactly
yeah yeah you should know this you know
in if you're a doctor you have to keep
learning the new medical practices you
can't you can't go doing [ __ ] you know
like in the 1960s are you a covenant
here's some leeches but you know what i
mean like we don't you can't do that the
only difference is there's regulations
yeah and you're forced to do it yeah but
god imagine if there wasn't people
people would never [ __ ] update their
thing
and then a reason why they do it is
because it's to the detriment of
everyone else around us yeah the problem
is with youtube it's not an instrument
of anyone else if a content creator
falls off there are tons more you know
what i mean it is up to you to make sure
that you are making stuff you are
updated
when my channel falls off there can be
plenty of uh [ __ ] uh kirby enthusiasm
memes of this section of the podcast
yeah and i i'll i'll you know it's if i
stop trying to change that's on me if i
don't want to do that anymore i
understand
my favorite comments i get though is
like it's not even the you've changed or
the i like the old content better it's
the you've fallen off
comments
yeah you're irrelevant now and i'm like
what because you personally don't like
my stuff now i'm subtly irrelevant in
the grand scheme of things it's like
dude yeah i mean yeah there's people who
are not gonna like what you know and
that's fine like i'm not i'm not trying
to appeal to everybody yeah like if you
like if you don't like it
that's cool dude there's literally
thousands of content creators you could
go and watch yeah that's not strange
it's strange i
i don't really know what's your opinion
gone tell me your opinion my opinion on
changing
whatever the [ __ ] you want our opinion
on yeah
no i mean like
for me like changing changing is part of
part of our job
and life i think you should change as a
person yeah absolutely when i when i go
back and see my friends from school if
they're exactly the same as they were in
school i'm like that's a red flag why
yeah but some people don't change you
know
did you notice that going back i did i
did and i don't
i i
don't give a [ __ ] if they haven't that's
on them it's i think it's like oh
that's odd like nothing has changed your
point of view in life in five years like
nothing has made you think different not
none of your experiences have changed
who you are okay fair enough yeah but
then i don't want them to be like oh
you've changed it's like it's like yes i
have get over it well yeah of course
i've changed i
i moved to a foreign country and i have
no idea what's going on after the
[ __ ] time and i barely know how to
communicate with my taxi driver yeah of
course i've changed yeah i'm fighting
for my life man yeah exactly
exactly no because i feel like that just
says a lot of us about us as people
because i'm i'm constantly looking for
change i'm like same sorry i i am like
uncomfortable when things stay the same
for too long nothing that's that's why
that's why you're [ __ ] i get scared
when [ __ ] starts to get monotonous right
like which which is kind of makes
youtube my perfect job because i i never
want to stay still i i'm constantly
wanting to change not just like just
like in korea but in like my own life
like that's why i've moved countries so
many [ __ ] times i still don't know
why i want to settle down yet because
i'm like scared to like stay in one
place for too long you know i just you
know that's just that's just me as a
person i constantly like changing my
life and i'm not saying if
if you are the type of person who
doesn't change and stays comfortable in
one place there's nothing inherently
wrong with that but all i ask is you
don't judge
us for changing changing for changing as
well and you know there are some people
in some people who i was mates with back
back in the day that i have less in
common with now and that's just part of
me having to accept that i have changed
and we have less in common we're not
going to push our values on you guys so
you know just don't do this
yeah sure except for drip you should buy
drips
well i'll give my opinion you have to
take it but
absolutely i'm so very brash with my
opinion i know that yeah
yeah i'm not going to cry over you not
agreeing with me like i don't care i do
get annoyed people completely
misinterpret what i'm saying yeah that
doesn't yeah yes actually i'm like how
did the [ __ ] did you get that like yeah
what yeah
you're you're starting a completely
different argument